[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com okay let's talk today about
Iran Venezuela and Syria and I mentioned
yesterday that I want to discuss the
Putin angle on the latest Iran stuff but
I also want to talk about it in the
larger context and there's a really good
post about this on our subreddit david
pakman.com slash reddit which outlines
sort of the underlying idea that i want
to present to you here and it's
something i've been thinking about i
thought about it over the weekend as the
iran news was breaking and i've
continued thinking about it and the idea
is that in the end donald trump may be
destined to stay out of iran and stay
out of venezuela and ultimately stay out
of syria in any serious way because
staying out of those three countries
shares a common thread which is that
it's in vladimir putin's
and russia's interests for the united
states to stay out of those three
countries now III know i know that i
have to issue this disclaimer I hope we
can be mature here okay this is not
Putin is literally telling Trump what to
do although who knows what they've
talked about in private we actually
don't know but it's the trend once again
that in the end when the rubber meets
the road
Trump ends up taking the path that is in
Russia's interests and this is not about
collusion or Trump criminality or
anything like that
it's about geopolitical realities it's
about the realities of the dynamics that
are forming as I've talked to you about
many times now among the three major
superpowers right now the United States
China and Russia in a way that is not
very good for the United States under
Donald Trump Iran Venezuela and Syria
are three allies of Russia and the trend
in Donald Trump's presidency it's not a
hundred percent but it's a high
percentage is that in the end rhetoric
aside Trump ends up acting in a way
that protects or doesn't go against or
threaten Russia's interests and let's go
through them one by one here Trump does
a big boy and he attacks Syria except he
attacked an empty runway at an airport
after telling Russia that he was going
to do it and it was back up and running
within a couple of days if not more like
hours and so for all of the tough talk
Trump does effectively nothing now this
doesn't mean I want Trump intervening in
Syria what we're doing here is an
analysis of how Trump's actions relate
to Russia's interests not me saying I
want Trump to take a B or C action
that's Syria Venezuela number two in the
winter as I told you last week Donald
Trump was looking very hard at going
into Venezuela forcing regime change to
be clear I don't want him to do that I'm
glad that Donald Trump didn't do that
don't email me saying I want Trump to
intervene in Venezuela because I don't
but last week I told you that there are
some new reports from inside sources
would say that Donald Trump simply got
bored and sort of lost patience with the
complexity of the entire Venezuela thing
which is totally believable but once
again in the end it favors Vladimir
Putin Putin and the shabbos Maduro
regime are tight we know that much of
the change in Donald Trump's focus on
Venezuela happened after a phone call
with Vladimir Putin in early May and
once again in the end Donald Trump takes
the path that at least in the immediate
is the one that protects Russia's
interests and favors favors Vladimir
Putin and then number three we now have
Iran yes the bluster against Iran the
threats the sanctions and threats of
sanctions backing out of the Iran deal
the entire thing we told you about
yesterday including Donald Trump
authorizing a strike against Iran over
the weekend but then calling it off says
it was over civilian casualty estimates
which may be true but once again Trump
despite the domineering rhetoric ends up
taking the action or more accurately not
taking the action that favors Vladimir
Putin and is in Russia's interests so
again please don't make this out to be
me saying anything other than what I'm
actually saying I am NOT saying Trump is
personally colluding with Putin
on these three foreign policy situations
I'm not alleging to alleging or pointing
to some kind of conspiracy I'm pointing
out that in the end Donald Trump is
taking the paths here that Putin would
want him to take if you're concerned
with what's in the United States best
interests then you have to be concerned
about the u.s. increasingly being in a
weak position relative to the two - the
two other major superpowers Russia and
China who as I've told you before are
increasingly working together at the
disadvantage of and exclusion of the
United States now maybe you don't care
about that I mean there are people who
even though they might live in the
United States as most but not all of our
audience does who don't care if the
United States is better or worse
position than they say we're all humans
I don't care about country borders and I
don't care as long as we raise the
overall well-being that's my concern I
don't care what happens to the United
States many of us even on the Left who
live in the United States are invested
in the United States being a good place
to live in a place that has a good
standard of living and the relationships
we would like to see with other
countries and so we do care about this
so please don't start with the you know
I must be a war monger stuff because I'm
criticizing Trump for not going into
Iran Syria or Venezuela
I want Bashar al-assad out for the sake
of the Syrian people but not at the
hands of the United States I think the
United States needs to stay totally out
of Venezuela I do not want Donald Trump
starting a war with Iran this is not
about me personally these erratic
maneuvers by Trump are odd baiting Iran
into action pulling the u.s. out of the
Iran deal getting the opportunity to
keep escalating and then now last minute
bailing on the escalation if a
democratic president had done this it
would be every low-rent right-wing
analyst on Fox News 24/7 talking about
how weak Obama or Hillary or whoever was
by virtue of taking the action that
Donald Trump has taken so my concern is
the underlying geopolitical concerns
that exist here and number two whether
Donald Trump is actually in the end
making the decisions that
even he believes are in the best
interests of the United States I know
that I wouldn't agree with his
conclusions about what's best for the
United States but at least I would like
to believe that in good faith that's
what his decisions are informed by even
if I would disagree with the conclusions
it's not clear that that's going on
based on how at least these three
situations are playing out in the end
let me know you're thinking about this
and play if you're gonna do the
conspiratorial you know allegations
don't even bother I'm not going to
respond I'm not going to engage but if
you have a serious thought about what
I've laid out here I actually do want to
hear from you we've gotten away from
using the term [ __ ] as an insult or in
casual language in modern American
society because it's not good for people
who actually suffer from Down's syndrome
it's not good for their families and
their friends it's not good to use that
term about people with other cognitive
and intellectual limitations but this
apparently hasn't stopped the Iranian
president from seemingly seriously
claiming that Donald Trump suffers from
mental retardation this was during a
live televised address at least
partially commenting on the new US
sanctions against Iran the president
Donald Trump has announced Donald Trump
of course imposing these new sanctions
on Iran the Iranian president Hassan
rouhani calling the sanctions outrageous
and idiotic and adding that quote the
White House is afflicted by mental
retardation and does not know what to do
as translated and reported by The
Associated Press from the native Farsi
there are other translations that are a
little bit softer suggesting that the
terms cognitive limitations are
something along those lines were
actually what was used a disagreement
about exactly how it should be
translated from Farsi now almost as
importantly but maybe not quite
pragmatically the iranian president also
saying quote you sanctioned the foreign
minister simultaneously with a request
for talks and this goes to the erratic
and sort of a very strange nature of
what donald trump has been doing with
regard to Iran that I talked about in
the first segment at which we discussed
the undeniable reality that in the end
when you put the bluster and the
rhetoric aside Donald Trump's action
actions are going mostly in line with
what a Vladimir Putin with Russia as the
top priority would want Donald Trump to
do if four years ago I had told you that
in 2019 world leaders would be calling
each other
Rocketman and mentally [ __ ] I
wouldn't have believed it maybe some in
our audience would but here we are in
2019 and there's this hilarious double
standard among trumpets who all of a
sudden now are pretending that mentally
[ __ ] is outside the lines and an
inappropriate way to talk about Donald
Trump when they've spent the last almost
four years calling anyone that disagrees
with them a [ __ ] world politics under
Obama let's generate productive dialogue
for the mutual betterment of all humans
on earth world politics under Trump who
is the biggest [ __ ] or cuck or low
energy person and truly to take this
seriously for a second because it is
serious people with Down's syndrome
often care about others and express
significant empathy Donald Trump
actually seems to be completely lacking
that like aside from this being meant as
an apparent insult most people with
intellectual disabilities seem to be
better people than Donald Trump
who exhibits cruelty his bullying nature
greediness complete self-absorption in
every way and Trump meanwhile responding
that Iran the Iranian president's mom is
gay or something like that
I'm kidding but seriously Trump is
actually unstable enough that calling
him mentally [ __ ] could actually
trigger a war it could actually trigger
military action remember that Donald
Trump just a few days ago approved the
strike on Iran without even considering
civilian casualties later he was told
what they would be I believe about a
hundred and fifty and then he canceled
the attack or at least he claims that's
the reason why this has the potential to
completely derail Trump and meanwhile
the Trump administration is still
preaching it has leverage around the
Iran deal which Trump backed out of John
Bolton Donald Trump's national security
adviser again is saying all options
remain on the table with Iran if they
exceed
the uranium enrichment limit that is put
in place by the 2015 Iran nuclear deal
Trump pulled us out of the deal the
United States has no authority to
enforce that deal because Trump pulled
us out of it you can have the discussion
and we have had it already by the way
you can argue there are still other
signatories to the Iran nuclear deal
that have not backed out the UK Germany
our European allies and maybe you could
say they have the leverage to enforce or
demand the enforcement of that deal
although the United States has made it
quite difficult for them to actually do
that the United States has given away
all credibility and leverage to demand
adhering to that deal given that we
pulled out of it and it is absolutely
pathetic that even on corporate media
some Trump lackeys flunkies flax flax or
flunkies Blackie's I think that's going
to be another Urban Dictionary term
Trump flunkies are being allowed to say
this that hey Iran still has to stick to
that deal that's going to be up to our
allies to decide whether they want to or
can't even enforce that after the United
States has departed from the deal no one
in the Trump administration should even
be mentioning the requirements of the
Iran deal because we are no longer part
of that deal if you disagree with me let
me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day who are supporting the david pakman
show directly are Catherine Wilson and
Ray Feeny Catherine and Ray thank you to
both of you really appreciate your
support also want to say thanks to
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day Roger Lynn Roger has been a
david pakman show member for almost five
years and one year of membership is
great five years of membership even
better join catherine ray and roger by
signing up it takes under one minute
it's cheap it really supports the work
that we do and you get some really great
perks including a daily Members Only
bonus show at WWE a common comm coupon
code available if you want it but by no
means should you feel obligated to take
it this is 20 20 is a coupon code that
will save you 40% okay if someone came
to me and said David did you rape this
woman I would say I would never rape
anyone the characteristics of the person
wouldn't be a factor if they were
attractive if they weren't attractive it
wouldn't make a difference if they were
male or female it wouldn't make a
difference
I just don't rape anybody and that would
be my focus Donald Trump however has
previously talked about the
attractiveness or the type of woman when
he has denied various rape and sexual
assault allegations and there are many
of those and he's done it again Donald
Trump gave an interview to the hill
yesterday including to cigar and jetty
who interviewed me last week on the hill
TV and Donald Trump has denied the
allegation from a Jean Carol saying
she's not my type with all due respect
an indication that as far as Donald
Trump is concerned this is not an
attractive enough woman for Donald Trump
to consider raping take a look at the
exact quote from Donald Trump I'll say
it with great respect number one she's
not my type
number two it never happened it never
happened okay totally lying
I don't know anything about her I know
nothing about this woman I know nothing
about her she is it's just a terrible
thing that people can make statements
like that I say this with respect she's
not my type is code for she's not
attractive enough for me to want to
sexually assault her or to rape her but
of course her appearance and her type
should make no difference to someone who
doesn't sexually assault or rape women
the right answer here is I didn't rape
her because I've never raped anyone and
I would never rape anyone or sexually
assault anyone or use physical force to
get anyone in a situation like the one
that is described if you're asked if you
raped someone and you say no she's not
my type that suggests there's a type you
would be willing to rape or sexually
assault he's not denying that if she
were his type he might have or would
have sexually assaulted her or raped her
and remember Trump is accused of raping
his first wife there are under oath
documents from the divorce proceedings I
believe it is there may be some other
kind of court proceeding about this
Trump also by saying she's not my type
is continuing this idea that rape is a
sexual act when it's a very violent act
in reality it's the exercising of power
over someone else but that's probably a
few levels too deep for this
conversation or at least any
conversation involving Donald Trump and
for everyone talking about another lying
woman lying about Trump raping her
sexually assaulting her 16 allegations
of sexual assault have not taken Donald
Trump down so far he even got himself
elected after the grabbing by the [ __ ]
recording would anyone be dumb enough to
think that if they add their name and
make themselves number 17 or number 18
on the list of people that Donald Trump
allegedly sexually assaulted would
anyone really at this point be dumb
enough to think that that's going to
pull Donald Trump from office which gets
us to the idea that these women are
motivated by what right I mean becoming
rich and famous by saying that you were
raped because Rhea
victims end up leading such charmed
lives she's getting death threats from
trumpets which I'll talk about next why
do you think so many rapes go unreported
so these ignorant trumpets who come up
with just ridiculous bogus defense after
ridiculous bogus defense they seem to
have no understanding whatsoever of just
basic human psychology and live in a
complete and total bubble about how rape
accusers are treated in society
particularly when they say that the
person that accused them is a prominent
Republican politician we've seen that
we've got a number of examples of how
that goes it doesn't lead to a
particularly thrilling and exciting
charmed life and the idea that that
would be the motivation aside from not
being based in fact in terms of basic
motivations there's no drama
demonstrable proof that that's actually
how it works out so now let's get
further into what's going on with eg and
Carol I told you yesterday that once
again Donald Trump has been accused of
rape I don't know how many total rape
and sexual assault allegations this
makes I read one piece that says eg in
Carroll is number 16 another that says
she's number 13 others say 17 I don't
know what the answer is but the latest
accuser is Jean Carroll who says that
Donald Trump raped her in a New York
City department store in the late 1990s
she goes into specific and very explicit
detail about it
somehow this garnered very little
corporate media coverage nothing I was
able to find on the Sunday morning talk
shows two days ago only a little bit of
coverage yesterday Joe Biden standing
too close to a woman apparently deserved
a ton of coverage but yet another
accuser who says the President of the
United States raped me
gets relatively little coverage and
unfortunately and this leads to what I
was talking about earlier that accuser
Jean Carroll has now started to receive
death threats as was described to a CNN
reporter yesterday when Joe Biden stands
too close to a woman Joe Biden is the
problem according to the right-wing
Trumpets when a woman accuses Donald
Trump of rape
the woman who says she was raped is the
problem
- those exact same trumpets and this is
why there's a fundamental problem in
fighting people for whom this is just
sport I talked about this last week we
can't stoop to their level because it's
an immoral level but at a certain point
we also need to win and take them out of
power so look at the double standard
with the Al Franken and the Roy Moore
situations by the way Roy waters running
again and we'll talk about that soon
maybe later on this week when Al Franken
was involved in an arguably tasteless
joke involving a female reporter and a
flak jacket Republicans demanded that Al
Franken resign and Franken did resign
after even some Democrats said he should
probably go and he resigned his seat
from the US Senate in retrospect there
are many people now on the Left who say
you know given all the stuff that
Republicans have excused it's not
stitute totally clear that Al Franken
should have resigned but he did resign
meanwhile you had Republican candidate
for US Senate from Alabama Roy Moore who
was accused of multiple instances of
sexual assault including against teenage
girls and he received forty eight point
three percent of the vote from Alabama
voters he lost by under twenty two
thousand votes Democrats have plenty of
scumbags but the rules are not even
remotely the same for how Republicans
and Democrats handle this stuff who was
defending Anthony Weiner a Democrat who
has caught multiple times sexting with
various women now I don't even remember
what I believe one of them was underage
who was defending John Edwards a
Democrat for his mistress Fiasco the
details of which I don't even remember
now I'm sure you can find someone in a
country of 340 million people certainly
there were some people defending Anthony
Weiner and John Edwards but it was few
and far between Newt Gingrich's affairs
while his wife had cancer Donald Trump's
affairs and 15 16 17 sexual assault
allegations
Roy Moore serial accused sex assault er
gets 48% of the vote how do we defeat
people who have no rules and see this
only as the sport of wins and losses and
not as real people and real life I don't
know the answer okay but at a certain
point we've got to start winning and
this is you know I'm not playing coy and
saying oh damn Democrats are victims of
their own morality and Upstate there's
plenty of scumbags who are in power
there's plenty of scumbags who defend
those in power who do bad things on the
left but they're playing by different
rules at this point in time so I don't
know what the answer is but it's
abundantly clear that Trump supporters
are not going to be influenced by
allegation after allegation after
allegation and one way or another this
is a guy who has to be removed but
remember that this is a symptom okay
the fact that evangelicals voted for him
even though he goes against everything
they claim to stand for the fact that
they are totally unwilling to just say
hey this has to stop this is not a good
guy it it is not something that is going
to go away if and when Donald Trump is
removed from office or leaves office in
a year and a half or five and a half
years and this is a bigger sort of
corseting of the dialog corseting of
morality that we are going to at some
point need to deal with and I genuinely
don't know what the answer is if you
have ideas let us know we'll have a
question about this a poll question on
the David Pakman show
Instagram page later on today or maybe
later this week that's at David Pakman
show on Instagram and while you're there
follow me i'm at david pakman on
instagram quick break back after this to
talk about which centrist democrats
should be be top priorities to primary
with more progressive challengers that's
coming up next
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to welcome back
to the program Jeff Cohen who's a
journalist media critic founder of
fairness and accuracy in reporting and
co-founder of rootsaction.org 'its for
progressive primary challenges I think
Jeff for reasons that I'll explain
shortly my audience will be pleased to
hear me talking about this so I mean
let's just talk first about the the
general principle in other words how
should we be thinking of when it makes
sense to invest resources in primary a
seat currently held by a Democrat well
people have to understand that
challenging an incumbent is not easy you
will generally lose but what we argue in
this report is that if you run a strong
primary challenge against the corporate
Democrat or a problematic Democrat and
you don't win it still helps you get
progressives organized within that
district it helps you win elections
later and it puts a scare into the
incumbent to start serving the interests
of the constituents more than the
corporate donors so even if it's going
to be a seat that ultimately stays with
the incumbent Democrat there are still
specific reasons why it's valuable to
challenge some many or all of them no
doubt about it that a forceful challenge
is a success we've seen this so many
places where you don't knock out the
incumbent Congress member but some of
the activists who've learned electoral
skills they then become members of the
City Council or the County Council it
really helps build
and I'm not talking about running 2%
protest campaigns I'm talking about
getting in the Democratic primary
running a good campaign learning the
electoral skills even if you don't knock
out the incumbent it's still worthwhile
so where my audience has sometimes
disagreed with my position on this is
that I've said I'm all about moving the
Democratic Party to the left I want to
look at Senate seats I want to look at
the House of Representatives I'm
completely with you but my pragmatic
side also recognizes that in a world of
not unlimited resources and that there
are some limits in terms of how much
money there is to be invested in any
particular state district or seat there
is some calculus to be made about okay
if we have the option of trying to
primary one Democrat versus trying to
flip to red seats to blue that it's okay
to make more specific analyses of
particular districts and states and that
sometimes the right answer might be to
leave a relatively centrist Democrat be
for some other goal that may be a higher
or more achievable or productive goal is
that general calculus something that you
agree with or disagree with I agree with
that up to a point
obviously progressives in and their
organizations within a locale need to
decide how best to deploy those
resources but I began and the whole
organization rootsaction.org began in
2011 because we came to this conclusion
there isn't just one problem facing our
country which is the impression you get
from MSNBC and at certain news outlets
which is right-wing extremism right-wing
republicanism we believe an equal
problem is that the Democratic Party
leadership is so corporatized and so
ineffective in fighting for social
economic racial environmental justice so
if you begin with the idea that there
are two problems sort of equal problems
then I think you and I would agree
that sometimes it makes sense to go
after a Republican and try to flip it
but a lot of the times it makes sense to
go after the corporate Democrat because
frankly in these these bad blues in this
report we just put out with 15
incumbents that should be primary 12 of
them are in completely democratic
districts five of them are in districts
where the Democrats win by 40 50 70
points when you know Hillary versus
Trump sure
and if you don't primary a bad corporate
problematic tired Democrat you really
have no congressional election in your
district it doesn't exist that's exactly
right yeah and I think that your it
sounds like we mostly agree I mean I
sometimes think about West Virginia
where you've got Joe Manchin arguably
the most conservative Democrat in the
Senate and you have three house
congressional districts it's interesting
the idea of primary know Manchin at the
same time when I look at you know the
second district which is Alex Muniz were
he won by the smallest margin of any of
those three I don't know I mean maybe it
makes more sense to try to flip that
than to try to primary Manchin given the
full calculus of the state's demographic
you know voting voting demographics and
everything I don't know like it is it
crazy to think maybe the resources are
better spent trying to flip one of those
three congressional districts rather
than fighting Manchin I'm not sure yeah
I'm not an expert on those three
districts but I'm not arguing with your
rationale that progressives need to be
strategic I'm not for like Green Party
campaigns where you win 2% of the vote
and yeah that's not what we're talking
about we're talking about running in
poor serious progressive campaigns and
in some places where there are limited
resources you may be right but I have
found as I travel around the country you
know I do lectures and they bring out a
crowd and there's a lot of activists
that one of the great frustrations is
people that are saddled sometimes 4 10
20 30
years yeah with a Democratic Congress
member in a very blue district who's not
getting the job done who's pro-corporate
pro-war and doesn't stand up to trump
and in those districts if you're going
to have any kind of a congressional role
as a constituent you're going to be
running in the Democratic primary
against the incumbent so obviously in
some districts it won't make sense I
would argue in many districts it does
make sense to primary a problematic
Democrat so the 15 that you've
identified in the report is there some
common thread in terms of political
positions that is is visible across all
15 that you believe is sort of the most
pernicious of elements that makes you
say these are the 15 we should target
yeah and remember we said at the
beginning of the report the following
report is far from exhaustive it's
merely illustrative there's far more
than the 15 that should be primaries but
the 15 we profiled yes I would say the
one thread is corporatism these are
people that when push comes to shove
side with corporate power over
working-class middle-class and poor
people in their district now there are
some that are extreme I mean there are
three on our list Schrader in Oregon
Cuellar in Texas and Kosta in California
they get Koch brother money I mean
there's so far right-wing they're almost
Republicans but then there are the
people that are like Meeks Meeks is in a
district in Queens where Hillary beat
Trump by 70 points and he's completely
allied he's liberal on some issues but
he's completely allied with Wall Street
that district should have a progressive
and so but those are the main thread I
think is these are people that when push
comes to shove they identify with their
corporate donors and not middle class
and were
can cause people broadly defined this is
where I think the representatives
currently in the Democratic Party are
furthest from the electorate in the
sense that over the last 10 20 25 years
you've seen the American electorate in
general move to the left on a number of
different issues many of them are social
right so when you look at abortion when
you look at gay marriage when you look
at the role of religion in government
for example but on the corporate stuff
it seems as though the difference
between many Democrats and almost all
Republicans is so small compared to
where the Democratic voters are on this
issue yeah I agree with that a hundred
percent and a big issue for us is war
spending I mean Trump asked for the
biggest military budget in history last
year and he basically got it
Pelosi immediately issued a statement
how she's working with Trump to to get
the military spending he wants Schumer
issued a statement and what we found
here is you've got a lot of these
Democrats who claim they want to tighten
the belts you know they want to be
fiscally conservative because the Trump
Trump is not but they're always for more
military funding and so a big separating
line as you say is corporate issues and
another separating line is war issues I
mean one of the most vulnerable people
of the 15 is Elliot Angle he's the head
of the House Foreign Affairs Committee
but I'm foreign policy and war issues
and military spending
he's with the Republicans I mean
remember most Democrats in the House
voted no on authorizing Bush's invasion
of Iraq
Elliot angle of Bronx Westchester he
voted yes with bush most Democrats were
with Obama in the landmark let's step
away from war and let's have this
nuclear deal with Iran and angle was one
of the minority of Democrats who voted
with the Republicans against Obama's
nuclear deal right when Trump says we're
going to take this destabilizing he did
say it was destabilizing but it was move
of the US Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem
angle is one of the Democrats that
immediately embraces Trump so now angle
can be liberal on domestic issues but
what really charges him up and the power
he has in Washington is he's the head of
the House Foreign Affairs Committee but
he he basically has Republican foreign
affairs views
he should be out it's a completely
democratic district but thinking about
some of the strategy of running some of
these campaigns I mean what what is the
right way to go about them because often
when you see national groups and I'm not
pointing to here specifically but in
other in other cases sometimes when
national groups make decisions about
which districts should be targeted for a
B or C reasons there is not a very
genuine and authentic feel to some of
the primary challenges so what's the
right way to run these races well it's
it's complicated I mean obviously roots
action as part of that mix we really
respect justice Democrats we respect
working families party we respect our
revolution and progressive Democrats of
American democratic socialists of
America I mean they've all played a role
in successful campaigns justice
Democrats is so far endorsed in two of
our 15 districts they've endorsed
against Cuellar in Texas and they've
endorsed in New York against I think
it's angle or minx or Meeks the problem
what not to do and this is a problem
we're finding already for 2020 is that
in a number of these districts there's
two progressives that have gotten into
the race and two very strong
progressives and that's a way that helps
the Democratic corporate incumbent stay
in office so we know what one thing not
to do is split up the progressive vote
and as you've been pointing out split up
progressive energy so that's where
organizations are sort of important
early now in looking at the candidates
and deciding who's the most progressive
who can win and or who is the most
progressive who will run strong and then
try to convince people to rally around
that one candidate
I know it's often difficult because
there's often legitimate differences of
opinion very interesting report we'll be
linking to the work of roots action in
are the descriptions of the YouTube
video for our interview we've been
speaking with Jeff Cohen who's a
journalist media critic founder of
fairness and accuracy in reporting and
co-founder of roots action
always great to talk to you great to
talk to you and they can find the report
at Bad Blues org the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I have something really unfortunate to
talk about today it appears as though
YouTube may be generally messing with
independent news and politics channels
like the channel we have which now has
close to 700,000 subscribers now I can't
speak as broadly about this as I would
like to but I'll tell you what's going
on with our channel as a data point in
the last several months including with
the Steven crowd or Carlos Mazda Fiasco
and for other reasons there have been
lots of people making allegations of
political bias within news and politics
at YouTube there are allegations that
YouTube is going after right-wing
channels specifically de prioritizing
them D monetizing them because they are
right-wing there are others who say it's
left-wingers on YouTube that are
actually being hurt by changes to the
YouTube algorithm and my position has
basically been the same for a long time
now which is YouTube is prioritizing
what makes them money by keeping
advertisers happy there is a lot of
crazy right-wing content on YouTube
that's going to get caught up in that
that includes conspiracy stuff it
includes racist stuff it includes white
nationalist content and separatist
content and there's also some left-wing
stuff that's going to get caught in
there when left-wing channels talk about
ongoing conflicts whether they are in
Syria or Iraq or Saudi Arabia Yemen
whatever the case may be
there are algorithmic decisions that
YouTube is making that are going to
disproportionately hurt the left-wing
channels talking about those issues and
they will not hurt for example the
YouTube channels of corporate media
outlets that are talking about those
exact same issues and there have been
continued allegations through and
through that YouTube is specifically
going after one or the other side of the
political spectrum but what I'm here to
tell you today and I'm gonna back it up
with some data is that at minimum there
is an a political targeting not of left
or right wing content but of independent
content which is I believe being
deprioritized in lieu of corporate news
channels we are getting absolutely
crushed on YouTube as a result of the
algorithmic changes that have gone on
now I can't
say if this is because of one thing or
another what I can tell you is that this
predates the steven crowder Carlos Mazda
Fiasco it may have been exacerbated by
that but this is bigger than that and
it's really just genuinely bad for our
channel to make money on YouTube you
need views and the views need to be
monetized meaning it's not just views
but the views need to have ads play
before them in order for us to make
money now there are a bunch of different
ways that we get views on YouTube one
big way is called browse features browse
features include we have close to
700,000 subscribers on YouTube when
those people see our videos on their
homepage under their list of
subscriptions that is called a browse
feature view if someone views our
channel through something like that it's
mostly a function of subscribers the
more subscribers you have the more
Browse feature views you are going to
get there's another one which is called
suggested videos which are those videos
that YouTube suggests alongside on
desktop or below on mobile the video
that you are watching and this is a
hugely variable source of views and it
is dependent on YouTube's algorithmic
priorities our portion of views that
come from this suggested video feed has
declined by about 50%
back in September about 33% of our views
were coming from the suggested view
suggested features a sort of umbrella
that number has dropped from 33% to
under 17% and I'll explain to you why
this is such a big deal this is about
half of what we were once getting from
this algorithm and this decline started
right after YouTube announced that in an
effort to crack down on fake news it
will be doing more backing as they say
of what they call authoritative sources
and of course what might be a
well-intentioned good-faith effort to
crack down on fake news appears to be
absolutely crushing independent
producers
like us this decline from 33% to 17% of
our views coming from YouTube suggested
videos feed is a huge blow to our
revenue because it represents a ton of
views we had three and a half million
views in December not on the entire
channel just from the suggested video
feed okay in June we'll be lucky to get
one and a half million views from the
suggested video feed that's a two
million view shortfall okay that's a
huge revenue shortfall now I have to be
careful because my understanding is that
YouTube's Terms and Conditions say I
can't give you specific revenue numbers
so I'm not going to but losing two
million views because of changes to
YouTube's algorithm is a lot more money
than most people in the audience would
guess okay let me put it that way and in
the meantime
although YouTube is claiming that
they're putting in place a better more
efficient system to make sure the videos
that are brand safe do get ads playing
on them look at what happened yesterday
we had a video from yesterday get 90,000
views in the first four hours a very
this is in the top 1% of our videos by
getting 90,000 views in just the first
four hours this was a video about Donald
Trump's interview with George
Stephanopoulos where they talked about
Donald Trump's finances and the video
was instantly demonetised as you can see
from the yellow dollar sign on the
screen monetized videos have a green
dollar sign there is nothing not brand
safe in this video we appealed the
decision were told that those decisions
should be reviewed within an hour and it
was not reviewed for about 14 hours
until such time that the video had a
hundred and ten thousand views it has
now been romana ties but we lost the
revenue on one hundred and ten thousand
views so listen I have no control about
over this I have no control over any of
what's going on here channels like ours
are uniquely positioned to be the most
damaged from these algorithmic changes
and I'll explain what I mean by that the
big corporate news channel CNN whoever
they have huge ad revenue
outside of YouTube and YouTube is
favoring them anyway so they're fine
really small channels don't depend on
YouTube to fund ongoing multi employee
operations they're fine we who are in
the top one-and-a-half percent of
YouTube but not in the top point one
percent we are the people who will most
suffer so what can we do
I've said it before and I'll say it
again we've got two separate funding
from advertising that's it okay we have
direct support set up on our website
where we get 98% of every payment okay
we pay a two percent payment processing
fee ninety-eight percent of the
contributions through membership on our
website go directly to funding the show
we're looking at launching channels in
other languages with our content dubbed
in very high quality to reach people who
don't speak English we've started paying
for the subtitling and closed captioning
of our channel already we produce and
give the show to 200 non-commercial
radio and TV stations all of that stuff
costs money and under one percent of our
audience funds us directly through
membership right now if we can get to
two percent of our audience funding us
directly we laugh about these YouTube
issues we'll be in great shape if we can
get to three percent of our audience
funding us directly we would be
absolutely crushing it so this has to be
a wake-up call okay we've got to support
the shows that we value directly if we
can afford to do so if you can't that's
okay I'm still doing the show for you
okay I don't need your last dollar but
if you're used to buying one of those
lattes or two a month consider going to
WWJ pakman.com and saying I can afford
three bucks a month I can afford six
bucks a month the coupon code this is
2020 will save you 40% we're not talking
about a lot of money if you apply that
code to the $6 a month membership it's
three dollars and sixty cents a month
okay if you apply that coupon code to
the yearly membership it'll drop it from
$60 to just $36 let's make this happen
because this is this it's not any more
about this could happen
this is happening we have lost half of
our views on YouTube from the suggested
video feed and increasingly be
recommended the suggested videos are
corporate establishment legacy media
let's make this happen
okay I truly believe that our audience
is going to understand the importance of
this and I look forward to coming back
to you in a week and telling you how
inspired and flattered I am from the
audience support there is a conservative
a British politician who rung a
Greenpeace activists neck when she
interrupted a speech in the United
Kingdom a few days ago and I'm gonna set
this up for you mark field is a member
of parliament or an MP as they are known
in the United Kingdom he's 54 years old
he's a member of the Conservative Party
in the UK also known as the Tories and a
few days ago Chancellor Philip Hammond
was giving a speech about brexit at
what's called the bankers and merchants
dinner
Greenpeace Greenpeace is the climate
activist organization they sent 40
volunteers to D to this event to try to
interfere with the speech and get
attention for climate change one woman
was walking around there as part of this
protest and Mark fields got up and
grabbed her and pushed her and then
wrung her neck some might almost call it
strangling from behind although I don't
know that that's the right term in this
particular case and there is video so
immediately the question is is this
treatment too rough for someone that
seems to be one of 40 peaceful
protesters some have argued she could
have had a gun
hard to imagine from the dress she was
wearing that she had a gun not to
mention both of her hands were full of
items which would make it quite
difficult to even get a gun out of her
purse if that's what she had and where
she had it Fields is saying his reaction
was quote instinctive given the
circumstances and Fields has since
apologised to the woman there are other
MPs calling for this guy to go Labour MP
Tanya Antonio at sea says quote no one
who reacts like this to a peaceful
protest should be sitting in our
Parliament Liberal Democrat MP chuka
emunah says that the actions are
totally unacceptable former Tory MP
Sarah Wollaston says it was quote
absolutely shameful a male MP marching a
woman out of a room by her neck Labour
Minister Don Butler tweeted this as
horrific mark field must immediately be
suspended her sacked bottom line a woman
in a ball gown with high heels holding a
cell phone in a small purse is not the
threat that instinctively was apparently
what went to mark fields mind here it's
extremely difficult to buy that now some
people are making this a man versus
woman issue saying oh you're only upset
because the protestor was a woman but it
would have been totally fine if the
protestor had been a man there is no
question that gender is a factor here I
would argue it's a reasonable factor but
beyond that a sitting MP putting his
hands on a member of the public's throat
is now what we're defending I got an
email from a viewer saying the way this
guy reacted his entire posture his
entire demeanor during this is of a
classic domestic abuser I would not
argue that this guy is a domestic abuser
absent evidence that he is a domestic of
you abuser what I do believe is that
this is a level of aggression that did
come naturally to me to him in the
moment and I can also tell you that in
the United States far less aggressive
physical attacks than this often lead to
people being charged with battery so I
want to hear from you what do you think
about this if you've been listening to
the podcast a radio show and you you
didn't see the video that we just played
for a video audience find the video
online and let me know what you think of
it we have a voicemail number the number
is two one nine two David P received a
voicemail about reparations for black
Americans let's take a listen hi David
it's Mike calling and I was wondering
well I watched the congressional hearing
about reparations and it was very
interesting dialogue and I'm generally
supportive of the idea of reparations
but I do think that
the conversation going on right now does
have the potential to backfire against
the eventual Democratic nominee and it
has potential to ignite the far right
and it is just generally unpopular with
the wider American people although I do
think that we can make the argument for
it so thank you yes listen I don't know
about the popularity of reparations for
black Americans among the broader
American people I've not seen polling
about that here's my view on it I think
that there is a very valid and
completely reasonable moral and
philosophical debate to be had about
reparations for black Americans how many
generations after slavery does it go how
do you demonstrate that you are actually
descended from individuals that were
slaves in the United States rather than
from families that came to the United
States after slavery was abolished I'm
totally up for having that discussion in
practice unless Democrats get a
supermajority in the Senate I don't see
any way any way that reparations pass
and thus I believe that in 2019 right
now this is a distraction of a
conversation and I believe that it is
not a pragmatically smart path for
Democrats at large to go down that
that's that's my view I don't see any
way that you get a single Republican
when it comes down to voting in the
Senate or maybe more than three or four
Republicans I just don't see any way
forward for this and as a result I don't
think that it's particularly smart
politics to keep talking about this at
this point in time if you disagree I do
want to hear from you we will talk on
the bonus show today about how Bernie
Sanders with canceled student loan debt
and much much more including how Trump
advisor Kellyanne Conway is straight up
going to not show up to the hatch act
hearing that has been scheduled get an
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member or a patron
I will speak view them
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you